and we would like to begin pre-boarding  with our first class passengers  first-class passengers only please  next are business class passengers may  now board  okay and we would like to welcome our  Regal Alliance Elite members Regal  Alliance Elite members  okay now all passengers with children  anyone with small children can be bored  now  okay we would like to continue boarding  with uniform military personnel what why  kids this  is thank you for your service thank you  so much for your service God bless you  thank you for your service thank you for  your service all right people in  wheelchairs  any priests nuns rabbis imams what why  do they get special treatment  assalamualaikum I've never